Airships have always
gotten people's attention.
Airships are magical.
They're fascinating.
Whenever a film director or producer wants
to telegraph this is an alternate reality,
you'll see an airship in the sky.
We see that already.
There are several airship projects
that are already been initiated,
so it seems that the airship
industry has been reborn.
Nearly a century after
falling out of favor,
airships could be on the rise again,
this time as a potential
solution to one of
the most elusive problems in
aerospace, reducing emissions.
The tremendous amount of the
fuel burned by an airliner
is burned simply to stay in the air,
and an airship doesn't need to do that.
Backed by new research and technology,
companies are aiming to take
advantage of this free lift
to fill in some gaps underserved
by current infrastructure.
And of course, there's
always the excitement factor.
It's something that is very attractive
to people as an idea.
It's a type of aircraft that seems
to generate an emotional response
But for airships to go
from alternative reality
to a reality, they'll need
to support a business case
that can overcome nearly
a century of failure.
Oh, the humanity!
If you look at it, every
project ever failed
regarding large capacity airship.
You don't have large airship in the sky.
It's interesting that we
don't look back on things
like the Titanic as the end of shipping,
because shipping has been
an economically viable
and mainstream part of our
transport networks ever since.
The first thing to reshape that
narrative on the technology
is to make it an economically
viable proposition.
A century ago, airships, dirigibles,
and Zeppelins were at the
cutting edge of luxury transport.
Ferrying passengers non-stop
across the Atlantic Ocean,
decades before the jet age.
Today, the number of active
airships has dwindled
to a few dozen worldwide,
mostly used for novelty rides
or as floating billboards.
But a handful of brave companies
around the world are trying to make them
into a more common sight in the skies.
Some like LTA Research funded
by Google co-founder Sergey Brin,
have been rather secretive
about their plans.
Other companies have only
released computer-generated
visions of what they hope to build.
A few, however, have been able
to actually fly a prototype.
It is the largest aircraft in the world.
Makers boasted that they had created
a new breed of hyper-efficient aircraft.
This is the Airlander 10,
endearingly nicknamed
"The Flying Buttocks".
It makes up for what it lacks in style
by offering what could be
one of the greenest ways
to travel by air.
Using around 1.2 million cubic feet
of lighter-than-air helium,
the craft can cruise at a top speed
of about 80 miles per hour.
Originally designed as
a surveillance platform
by the U.S. military,
the project was canceled in 2013,
but UK-based manufacturer
Hybrid Air Vehicles
would eventually re-acquire the project
to bring it to market.
So, it's a carbon-fiber construction.
And as you can see, as you come in here,
into the flight deck element,
there's loads of space here.
If you are the pilot,
your view out is amazing.
From an aircraft-development perspective,
you can do a huge amount on paper.
You can do a huge amount in
simulation and wind tunnels,
but it's getting a new
configuration into flight.
That's the big milestone
because you learn a lot.
Its second test flight left
some onlookers feeling,
let's just say, deflated.
Oh my God, he's actually just broken it.
Thankfully, far from the
worst airship disaster
of all time, the Airlander
eventually returned
to the skies for more testing.
Since 2017, this Airlander
10 prototype resides mostly
in pieces at HAV's headquarters,
just over an hour outside London.
As troubling as it looks,
falling, ideally or gracefully,
is actually a key feature
of how the craft flies.
As the company name Hybrid
Air Vehicle suggests,
Airlander is what's
known as a hybrid airship
that is achieving lift from a combination
of conventional airship design
and aerodynamic attributes
from other flying aircraft.
The principal element at play is helium,
the lighter-than-air gas
that has the added perk
of being non-flammable.
Unlike the hydrogen that
doomed the infamous Hindenburg.
Just like a toy balloon,
with enough helium,
the ship will rise, essentially free lift.
The trouble with free
lift is it's always there.
And so we had to find a way
of making the aircraft work more easily
in terms of how things were
loaded onto it and off it.
And they made the operation
for the the whoever's flying it easier.
We've done that by making the aircraft
generate aerodynamic lift.
So it takes off and lands
like a conventional aircraft,
although in a really short space.
That lift is effectively
only lifting the payload.
That's the easiest way to think of it.
This means that without
the aerodynamic lift,
the craft is actually heavier than air,
more like an airplane.
Without the lift generated
by forward motion,
the airship sinks down
and more importantly,
stays on the ground.
And the reason that's important
is because getting on board
and offboard an airplane,
taking a shipping container
on board or offboard
an airplane, it's a lot easier
if you're on the ground.
And some of the large
airships would use, you know,
ground crews of up to
500 people to get them
out of hangers and move them around.
Even the smaller airships of today
have got significant ground crew.
With a hybrid aircraft,
we're on the ground for that
loading and unloading cycle.
It allows us to turn the
aircraft around quickly
and drive the economics,
the economic performance of
the aircraft as an asset.
This means the craft can take off
and land from any reasonably flat surface
like grass, water, or even ice.
And according to HAV,
the base model that uses
four combustion engines
will reduce CO2 emissions by
75% over comparable aircraft.
And future plans to have
a hybrid electric engine
would reduce emissions
by 90% with the goal
to eventually create a
truly emissions-free craft.
HAV believes that this
combination of technologies
will make Airlander both eco-conscious
and economically viable for applications
ranging from surveillance,
logistics, cargo transport,
and even passenger travel.
When I think about passenger transport,
it's such an exciting
space to move a technology
like this into because it
can change our expectations.
Right now, if we want to make
a journey here in the UK,
say, from the Northwest
of the UK to Ireland,
we've got a body of water to cross.
And our choices are to
travel out to an airport,
do it very fast, but very short flight
and then travel back in from the airport.
at the other end.
Or we can get on a
ferry that's three times
the journey length.
And the right thing to do here
from a carbon-footprint
perspective is to get on the ferry.
But it's such a time-impact for people.
With Airlander, what we offer is almost
a high-speed train of the sky.
Added to that, the aircraft
will go point to point.
It's not constrained to
airports that we have today.
So like a helicopter, it'll take off
and land away from the airport.
So we can open up a whole new journey.
I mean, an obvious example
is going to the North Pole.
HAV advertises that Airlander
will be able to carry passengers
to remote areas like the North
Pole on three-day excursions,
covering up to 2,000 nautical
miles at cruising speeds
of around 60 miles per hour.
A bit like with a helicopter,
you can similarly take
helicopters to almost anywhere,
but the range of a
helicopter's very short,
whereas, you know, we can
go on a three-day cruise
if you like, with a
stop at the North Pole.
Their first commercial target
is to bring this experience
to the luxury travel market.
So I'm sat here in our leisure
cabin demonstrator here
with the bar, with social spaces.
And what you can't see is down
at the other end of this
cabin from where I'm sat,
there are eight double-bedrooms
for overnight cruises.
This allows the leisure sector
to offer their clients
experiences that you
just can't get anywhere else.
Their approach hearkens back
to the early 20th century,
when luxurious airships
were the premium option
for well-healed passengers
on trans-Atlantic journeys.
But building a sophisticated-looking
bar and filling it
with an impressive wine selection is still
a far away from a happy hour in the skies.
Luxury travelers who
are going to be paying
a tremendous amount of money
are probably gonna compare
this maybe to a cruise ship.
They're used to having a private bathroom
with their bedroom.
They're used to doing
things like taking showers,
and you know, using water in the sink.
You need to cater to their needs
with a relatively high
staff-to-passenger ratio
if you're gonna deliver a luxury product.
And everything I just mentioned is heavy.
A cruise ship on the
ocean doesn't really need
to worry so much about
the weight of things.
You always have to look
at the alternative.
We're gonna use an airship
or we're gonna use X, right?
So let's say X is a high speed rail line.
So if you look at a place like Europe,
high-speed trains can connect
city center to city center.
And high-speed trains go a lot
faster than any airship can.
They carry a lot of people.
They're very environmentally friendly.
Are airship's beautiful,
and magical, and wonderful?
Of course they are, right?
But is a high-speed train
line make more sense
to go from Berlin to Hamburg?
Yeah, it probably does.
And in fact it almost certainly does.
HAV though, believes
Airlander can serve a gap
in areas where such
infrastructure is lacking
at a much lower cost.
Yeah, we've got hugely invested,
high-speed rail infrastructure in Europe.
There's lots of parts of the world where
a lot of movements are over water.
There's a lot of parts of the world
where we've got big geographic boundaries,
mountain ranges, and so forth.
And so, in both of those cases, you know,
the ability to put ground
surface infrastructure
is constrained.
You know, big infrastructure
programs needed
if you're gonna open up high-speed rail.
Big infrastructure programs
if you're gonna tunnel
under the sea, rather than fly over it,
where Airlander can step in
with a very infrastructure-light
solution and an experience.
And a travel experience is very equivalent
to a high-speed rail of the skies.
Beyond passenger travel,
the prospect of low-emission
transport without the need
for major infrastructure, could
also have a profound impact
in another space, cargo.
This is the LTA60T, an
airship with a cargo capacity
of up to 60 tons, making it even larger
than HAV's Airlander 10.
It's the dream of Paris-based company
aptly named "Flying Whales".
The reason why we created "Flying Whales"
is actually to solve a major
issue we have in France.
Forest industry was the second contributor
to the France trade balance deficit
because we have a lot of resource,
but there is no return
investment to build road
and tracks to pick up the logs
and bring it to the saw mill.
So we had to invent a
solution to go by the air
With funding from the French government,
"Flying Whales" began
to develop an airship
that could fly into the
remote mountains of France
to retrieve logs for
processing into lumber.
As you might guess from only
seeing computer-generated renderings,
the company has yet to
build a full prototype.
But they believe that
after nearly a decade,
they're getting close.
So we've been through,
something like four years
of what I call "de-risking
phase" on technology, markets.
It's actually, ultimately, it's
half-a-billion Euro project.
And you, you have to be sure
about what you do when
you invest so much money.
And in 2017, we were
pretty much all convinced
and then we actually launched
the engineering project.
So here is the global view.
You can see the external
shape details here,
the stations for the propellers.
On the left side, on the right side,
and also the stations
for the zed propellers.
We are very huge, 200 meters
in length and 50 meters in height.
And we have a rigid body
which means we don't
change shape according
to the environmental conditions.
This model of the LTA60T is designed
to carry wood logs, but the
company believes it can also
be used to efficiently
carry other cumbersome cargo
like high-voltage towers
or wind turbine blades.
Transporting large bulky items
on today's infrastructure,
let's just say, can run
into some challenges.
Oh, my God!
And for remote areas like Northern Canada,
it could open up entirely
new industries from resources
in regions lacking traditional
land or air infrastructure.
But with airships, loading
and unloading cargo
has a big technical caveat.
The load-exchange problem
in an airship carrying cargo
is that when you release the cargo
and you release its weight,
what's gonna stop the
airship from just popping up
into the sky because
it's now a lot lighter?
So you gotta exchange that load somehow.
There are a few different
ways to overcome this.
The most obvious solution might be
to dynamically adjust the quantity of gas.
But helium while much safer than hydrogen,
is also much more expensive to acquire.
So adding and releasing large
quantities during each flight,
isn't economically feasible.
But there may be another
physics-based solution here.
By compressing or
decompressing the helium,
you could change the airship's
lift while in flight.
This is ultimately the best solution.
And some of our competitors
are trying to develop this.
The problem we have with this solution
that it's very heavy.
Compressor and tanker are very heavy,
so it needs a lot of R and D.
And I think this technology
is gonna be available
in something like 5 to 10 years.
Until then, another option
is off-setting weight
with engine thrust,
but this would largely defeat
the efficiency benefits
of an airship in the first place.
Instead "Flying Whales" is considering
a more balanced solution.
If a trip calls for transporting say,
30 tons of wind turbine blades,
it would need to pick up another 30 tons
to replace the weight after drop off
with the help of thrusters
to help compensate
during the transfer process.
In the example of retrieving
wood from remote regions,
it would need to carry
the equivalent weight
in water on the trip out.
Then dispense that water
dynamically as it lifts wood
in order to achieve balance,
which visually at least, kind
of looks like a flying whale.
In theory, it can be simple,
but impractical, it is not.
Because it's a dynamic period.
And during this dynamic period,
you have to be very careful
on the equilibrium between
buoyancy and weight.
As if this didn't sound
complicated enough,
airships face another major
vulnerability, weather.
The side of an airship
is like a giant wall.
It's like a giant sail.
And there is something
we call "Sail Effect".
If you have a really, really big airship,
even a gentle wind multiplied
by the huge expanse
of the side of an airship,
can really move that airship in a way
that it can't move a smaller
vehicle, like a small airplane.
To compensate for wind,
the LTA60T has a series
of propellers positioned
all the around the aircraft.
These axes help us to control the airship
in a longitudinal, vertical,
and a directional way.
This ultimately limits application
to areas with stable-enough
weather conditions
where this weight
exchange can safely occur.
Despite all of these
obstacles, "Flying Whales"
still envisions viable
application for airships.
Transport business is very tough.
There is a lot of competition,
so margins are very small.
So it's useless to try to
come with a new solution, say,
"Okay, look, guy we're
gonna replace what you do
because we have a green
solution or a lock solution."
No, that doesn't work.
When the system is already existing
in the transport solution with low margin,
you cannot replace it.
So we just look at where we really provide
a huge gap in terms of cost or capacity
regarding the existing.
And in addition, of course,
we will strongly reduce
the environmental impact.
The niche that "Flying Whales"
is targeting is currently served
by a more common site
in the sky, helicopters.
Based on benchmark tests,
"Flying Whales" claims that their airship
could save 15 times the carbon emissions
and carry three times more payload
than the best performing
heavy-lift helicopters,
while still being cheaper to produce.
The helicopter has been
developed to transport
very, very fast people
from point A to point B.
I mean, planes have been
developed to go very fast,
very, very far.
Okay. In our case, we are
something like a flying crane.
We are today, the designer of the airship,
but tomorrow we'll be the
producer and the operator.
So, in the future, our business model
will be based on two things.
The production and direct
sale of the airship
by Flying Whales Industry.
And the transportation services provided
by Flying Whales Services.
"Flying Whales" hopes to be flying
their airship by late 2024.
In the meantime, they
will test and finalize
their design while working
with aviation regulators
to approve the designs for flight.
You know, building any new aircraft,
getting any brand new
aircraft design certificated
by the, you know,
certificating authorities
is a very, very expensive project.
Now, when you're building
on a previous iteration
of something, you know,
you're turning a 757 into
a 767 or a 727 into a 737,
you're still certificating new aircraft.
It's still a lot of engineering.
It's still a lot of expense,
but you're starting with something.
Building an airship in
the 2020s is sort of
starting with a blank
slate because nobody's
had a giant airship since the 1930s.
But what if money isn't everything?
At least in the beginning?
Achieving our goals in
preserving the planet
might take a mix of ingenuity
and adopting unconventional approaches.
And that begins with niche applications
of new, unproven, and
even unprofitable tech,
for the time being at least.
The two challenge you have is first
to prepare your shareholders.
It's gonna be very long.
It's gonna cost a lot.
Okay. And the second thing,
which is actually one
of my major challenge
is to keep your team motivated.
When you have a young
engineer coming in the company
and after two years, three
years, five years, six years,
you have to tell them,
"Well, you still have four years
before you're going to see that flying".
It is very difficult.
We are seeing a lot of
companies talk about airships.
We're not seeing a lot of
companies building airships.
There are things that an airship
can do better than anything else.
It's just that there are not very many
of those things, right?
It's always gonna be a niche player.
If it's gonna be a player at all,
it's going to fill a
very, very narrow niche.
Coming into this business
and leading this business,
it's been really, really important
to build our understanding
and build our customer's understanding
and finances understanding
of the market gap
that exists that we don't
usually spot because it's a gap.
We're not good and attuned at seeing gaps
until after somebody comes
and puts a product into them.
In aviation, we're dream
makers and dream deliverers,
and you get it right and that's true,
but you get the economics
wrong and it's not.